by now you've probably heard that the Arizona Supreme Court ruled
that the state of Arizona
can enforce a total abortion ban
that dates back to 1864
let me be clear
Arizona Republicans want to force all pregnant women
to non consensually carry their pregnancies to term
at the risk of their own health and life
by relying on a law that was enacted solely by men
at a time when women could not vote or participate in government
and the Arizona Supreme Court just gave them the green light to do so
let's talk about how we got here
in 1864 the Arizona Legislature enacted this total abortion ban
and it was enacted largely because of William Jones
who was a pedophile notorious for forcing children to marry him
including a 12
14 and 15 year old girl who he then forced to bear his children
so you can see why it was important to Jones and other men at the time
to be able to legally control women's reproduction
in 1971 Planned Parenthood sued the Arizona attorney general
arguing that this abortion law was unconstitutional
but then two years later in 1973
while this litigation is still going on
the US Supreme Court decides Roe v
Wade and makes abortion a constitutional right
so in the middle of this litigation
the Arizona courts like well
the United States Supreme Court
just said that abortion is a constitutional rate under Roe v Wade
so yeah obviously now the Arizona law is clearly unconstitutional
so the Arizona court says yep
the 1864 law is clearly unconstitutional under Roe v
Wade and they enact a permanent injunction
just meaning hey
nobody is allowed to enforce this 1864 law
but then in 2022
the US Supreme Court overturns Roe v
Wade in Dobbs v
Jackson Women's Health
so then Arizona's attorney general the time Mark Brnovich
goes to the Arizona court and he's like hey
you should lift that permanent injunction because now Roe v
Wade's overturned
and I wanna start enforcing that 1864 law
Planned Parenthood opposes Mark's motion on a number of legal grounds
and that litigation went on for nearly two years until last week
when the Arizona Supreme Court ruled that the 1864 law can go into effect
meaning that over 3 million women in Arizona
will have no choice over their pregnancies
because of a law that was enacted over 160 years ago solely by men
and who kidnapped and tortured us
now the law provides an exception for when a woman's life is in danger
and I put exceptions in ear quotes because these exceptions aren't real
there is litigation going on throughout the country because people
including physicians
have no idea
when a woman is sick enough to avail herself of one of these exceptions
the Legislature hasn't enacted some type of standard saying
this is when you can intervene
and even if they tried to
it's impossible
every person's pregnancy and health and situation is different
there's no workable standard for everyone
ruling will also have a devastating impact on reproductive refugees
because now New Mexico and California
are the only southern states on the border that have access to abortion
so not only can people no longer flee to Arizona
but we also have women fleeing out of Arizona now
and it's incredibly difficult for states like New Mexico and California
to continue absorbing all of these reproductive refugees
from anti choice locations
while also caring for their own citizens
okay let's pause there
did this help you understand what's going on in Arizona
um let me know your questions
your comments
and please donate to your local abortion fund